good morning good morning good morning
welcome to the surfy surfs on the trendy
trends and the tweety tweets
so i think i've come up with a name for
this um this streaming thing you know i
haven't really figured out what the hell
this thing is but uh you guys like to
you know go on the surfy search and the
trendy trends with me so i've been
trying to come up with a name for it and
i think i found a name
for this thing when i was a kid um you
know i
i'd do something wrong and i'd i'd end
up getting the attention of my parents
and normally it was it was my mom right
so she would say you're on my [ __ ] list
so i figured everything's trending
because of the the world's going to hell
in a handbasket that's normally what the
the twitter trends are and that's what
uh you know is today it's either actual
outrage or fake outrage that causes
things to get in the trendy trend and
the tweety tweets
so
so
i have decided to call this the
streaming
of the twitter trends the [ __ ] list
because they're on my [ __ ] list so this
this show is going to be called the [ __ ]
list roundup where we round up all the
trends
on the tweety tweets
to make the [ __ ] list so it's the [ __ ]
list roundup so we are going to uh round
up some [ __ ] list today so stay with us
because we got a lot of topics there's
the eastman memo uh candace owens uh has
this delusional
uh uh
delusion of australia and what australia
is and isn't and
somehow australia and american culture
um have crossed delusional paths here
and and it's it's i think it's because
of social media but we'll dive into that
trend
uh as we go along the other
the other trend is uh uh alec baldwin um
apparently on the set uh firearm was
uh loaded and automatic or
accidentally disfired and it killed a
cinematographer on the uh set of a movie
of a western that they're shooting uh so
that's so that's big news everyone's
talking about that so we'll talk about
that um also i i believe uh near
attendance in the news and a few other
things
so um let's let's just get right to it
let's i want to show you the countdown
uh but first off i did some audio of
this
so that you guys could really see the
shitless roundup and really get an idea
of it so let's start the shitless
roundup
[Music]